good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's very
early because I have to go to New York
this morning so here's a funny thing
that happened Hank Time magazine named
me one of the 100 most influential
people in the world so I'm going to New
York to go to this party now I am aware
I say this without sounding ungrateful I
am aware that this is an unearned honor
like I can personally name several
thousand people who are more influential
than I am who did not make the time 100
there's my beer Ian President Ellen
Johnson Sirleaf the actress and activist
Laverne Cox the artist Ai Weiwei also
every single morning French president
Francois Hollande wakes up and thinks
you know I think today I won't use
France's nuclear arsenal to start a war
that would end the human species and
that is an extremely influential
decision but that noted I am delighted
and honored to have been included and
now I get to go to this party with other
people on the time 100 like maybe
Vladimir Putin and Kim il-sung probably
not Kim il-sung however if he is there I
promise that I will take a selfie with
him and then I will make a citizen's
arrest for human rights violations one
more thing about the time 100 before I
get to the actual like topic of today's
video they called me a teen whisperer
which maybe you think about like what if
I were an actual teen whisperer like a
teens why are we gonna go to like take
drugs snapchat but it's true ink I know
what the teens love to talk about
Pulitzer prize-winning non-fiction books
about people living in a slum in Mumbai
alright I have to go to the airport but
you should come with me movie magic so I
like this summer in the nerdfighter book
club we're reading behind the beautiful
forevers by Katherine boo which is just
a fascinating book but there are times I
realize I didn't give you a due date
which is just terrible teaching on my
part I apologize so the movie of The
Fault in Our Stars comes out on June 6
things are going to be a little bit
crazy until then so June 10th you must
read this book by June 10th or else
nothing is going to happen to you also
if you're the kind of student who wants
extra credit and let's face it
nerdfighters you probably are and I
think it's really interesting the
beautiful forevers we need an acronym
for it like tiffy O's but to buff yes
but to buff anyway I think it's really
interesting to read Buddha both in the
context of another book about Mumbai
maximum City so that's your ex credit
assignment okay so no spoilers but I
want to talk about a few things to kind
of bear in mind while you're reading
behind the beautiful forevers first I
think it's really important to resist
the urge to extrapolate like this is a
book about a few people living in one
community
it's not a book about slums in general
or India in general also luck Hank we
like stories that make sense I mean
that's part of the reason we tell each
other stories part of the reason why we
read novels and watch movies and we're
hardwired to like stories that make
sense because human memory itself is
narrative so there's like a luck eraser
inside the human mind that tells you
that Z happened because of x and y but
actually z happened because of x and y
and lots of luck luck of birth and
genetics and circumstance and some
editor at Time magazine liking your book
so how does our view of the world change
when we incorporate luck into it instead
of assuming that human life is like
essentially a meritocracy okay a couple
other things the idea of private
property that's weird how does the land
become owned also water it's always
worth paying attention to water and
lastly when we talk about global poverty
we usually talk about people who live on
the equivalent of less than a dollar 25
a day that's the case for more than a
billion people but it's not the case for
the people Catherine Pugh writes about
who are living in an Wadi the people
living in an awadhi live above the
global poverty line and they're
participating in and some would say
benefiting from global capitalism but of
course what that actually means in their
lives turns out to be very complicated
and I think that's the great thing about
behind the beautiful forevers everything
is complicated governments nonprofit
organizations microfinance religious
organizations complicated people
complicated it's so good all right my
flight is boarding so I gotta go Hank
I'll see you on Friday global
international poverty retention week you
can have my Transportation Security
Administration mandates the removal of
does it really I'd never heard that
before